you're out the more the universe seems
comprehensible the more it also seems
pointless in your elaborate the little
wonder well that's not the last sentence
in the book if you look at the book then
there's another paragraph that follows
that that explains what I meant
of what perhaps I didn't explain it very
well I meant what I meant and that's
that statement is that there is no point
to be discovered in nature itself nature
there is no cosmic plan for us we are
not actors in a drama that has been
written for with us playing the starring
role there is there are laws we are
discovering those laws but they're
impersonal they're cold we are the
result of billions of years of accidents
we that have led to us governed by laws
of nature that have no care for us i but
then after it's saying that I went on
and say said that if there is no point
in in nature we can make a point for
ourselves we can find things to cherish
that we value we can love each other we
can create things that are beautiful and
also one of the things that some of us
find to give point to our lives is to
learn about nature it's not an entirely
happy view of human life I think it's a
a tragic view but that's not new to
physicists a tragic view of life has
been expressed by so many poets that we
are here without purpose trying to
identify something to care about even
when we find the final laws of nature we
won't know that why those are the
correct laws of nature but
although for example Shakespeare very
often expresses a tragic view of life
golden girl lads and girls all must like
chimney sweepers come to dust our
tragedy is a little different from his
from the heroes of Shakespeare's plays
for Lear and a fellow the tragedy is in
Shakespeare's script and what I like to
say is that our tragedy is that there is
no script oh we don't know it well we
don't know it and I could be wrong about
this of course I'm not certain about
anything but the more and more we
understand about nature we find no sign
of a script written for us and we have
to write the script ourselves where if
we're in the position of actors in a
tragic drama it's a drama we're
improvising as we go along